>>Student: We saw a bunch
of frost on everything,
so this is a picture of the bench.
>>Jordy: You've got your depth of
field right in the middle there.
How did you get it to do that?
>>Student: This playlist on YouTube
gave us all these good ideas.
>>Jessica: Because our kids can
discover the vast amount of resources
that they have access to, kids
are then able to seek out answers,
rather than just ask for them.
>>Jordy: You get to try and
figure it out by yourself today.
>>Student: Oh yeah.
>>Mark: When you get kids collaborating
together, they become more resourceful.
They see themselves as experts, and the
teacher can oftentimes not guide them
to the answer, but to another resource.
>>Jessica: Look around, people.
These are your friends that
might need your help today.
>>Kids need to learn teamwork based
skills, because every other class
and every other subject that they
have, third through eighth grade,
requires them to work in different sized
groups, accomplishing different tasks.
So the learning goal today was,
how do I solve problems using the
people around me as a resource?
>>Who has had a problem so far?
Sean?
>>Student: So I got a picture and
then everything just disappeared.
>>Jessica: Let's take a look
at this picture problem.
Do you guys want to help me out?
>>Students: Yeah.
>>Jessica: All right.
>>When we get to a certain point in
a project, there are so many people
that have the same type of problem.
>>Who is somebody that is an expert?
>>I try and remember who has had
similar problems and has gone
on to successfully solve them.
>>Student: First you go on the internet.
Then you click view image.
>>Jessica: Yeah, you got it.
>>Eloise: You get to help
people, and they'll help you.
Then you learn more and
make school easier.
>>You right click it.
>>Ooh, we got it.
>>Another strategy that I use when kids
are having problems or need assistance--
>>What's your question?
>>Instead of just having
students raise their hand,
I have a clothespin system
that I call the help desk.
>>We accidentally wrote it twenty B's.
>>Jessica: Oh man.
>>The clip indicates that I'm
having a problem with something,
and I need somebody's help with it.
>>Student: Our screen is frozen.
>>Eloise: I'm good at computers, so
people sometimes ask me to help them.
>>Probably turn it off
and turn it on again.
>>Jessica: So at a certain point, I say,
I'm now releasing anybody that's not
actively working to go and circulate
and help with some of
these clips as well.
They're psyched to be in that capacity.
>>Eloise: Is it the earth?
>>Sometimes I discover something
that I didn't know I could do.
>>Jessica: All right, time to celebrate.
>>At the end of class, we build
each other up with celebrations.
>>I want you to celebrate if
somebody was helping you today.
>>It's just a quick thing that gets
everybody fired up and really thinking,
well, what did this person do for me?
>>Student: Sophia helped
me do, like the pictures.
>>Jessica: Sophia, do you hear that?
>>Sophia: Yeah.
>>Jessica: How would you
like to be celebrated?
>>I have a menu on my
wall of celebrations.
>>All: [singing] Ah, ah, ah, ah,
you're really cool, you're really cool.
>>Jessica: So we create this environment
where kids have an excitement and a fire
for finding the right
resource to solve the problem.
>>You should feel really good
about what happened today.
>>Student: Thank you, Miss Heckman.
>>Jordy: In third, fourth grade,
one of the biggest goals is learning
to solve your own problems.
And so I get kids that already have
some of that when they come to me.
>>Yeah, you need to quit for now.
>>In life, we have to be
able to teach ourselves.
>>You need to make a new page.
>>In my class, students
come up with a project idea.
>>Student: My project
is learning Turkish.
>>Student: I'm learning
how to play the ukulele.
>>Student: I want to teach myself
how to get better looking photos.
>>Jordy: Students look at a template
that has a series of questions
that help them plan what
they want to do.
What do they expect to
learn from this project?
What steps are they going to take?
Who or what can they go
to when they get stuck?
>>Let's jump down to resources.
The people, the websites,
any books you used.
>>I'm not going to accept a proposal
where you don't have a resource to go
to if you get stuck, whether it's
an online forum, a YouTube channel.
>>Teacher: All right, Zoe, what's up?
>>Jordy: Another teacher,
a parent at home.
>>Teacher: So you're going
to make your own acid.
>>Zoe: Yes.
>>Teacher: That's the same
stuff that's in your stomach.
>>Zoe: We also learn managing your
time and kind of guiding yourself
without having as much, like
people telling you what to do.
>>Sodium chloride and--
>>Jordy: When you are in high
school, when you're in college,
when you're in the workforce,
there are going to be a set
of projects that are not well defined.
>>Zoe: Even though you're
learning hard stuff--
>>Jordy: Students are going to
hit road bumps along the way.
Can they get beyond those and
produce what they want to produce?
>>Mark: Because our students
are more resourceful,
they have more intrinsic motivation
within the learning process,
and ultimately are learning
to be learners.